BILL LUAN: Shanghai
GDG is a very
interesting developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER: This is,
primarily, a question and
answer show, so if any
of you out there
would like to ask questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: And we're
live, I think.
Our monitor is broken
so I don't know.
WOLFF DOBSON: Unless we're on
a YouTube stream, at which
point we're not live at all.
TODD KERPELMAN: So I'm
Todd Kerpelman.
I'm here with Colt McAnlis,
Wolff Dobson, John McCutchan.
We're here actually talking
about what happened to Google
Games chat number one.
COLT MCANLIS: Last week.
TODD KERPELMAN: Which--
WOLFF DOBSON: Where did it go?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Unfortunately--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Where was it?
TODD KERPELMAN: --it took
YouTube an awfully long time
to process.
So I think it just went
up yesterday.
And the ending got cut off,
which was the best part, those
of you who didn't see it.
It was totally the best part.
COLT MCANLIS: And There was--
if you were following the ticket
YouTube actually said
the problem was there was too
much awesome in it and--
WOLFF DOBSON: They couldn't
compress awesome well enough.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah,
we don't have--
WOLFF DOBSON: To fit inside
the bit rate.
COLT MCANLIS: At Google.
WOLFF DOBSON: Do we know
anybody at YouTube?
TODD KERPELMAN: I guess we'll
find out after this.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
TODD KERPELMAN: When we
get angry emails.
COLT MCANLIS: We'll get an
email here in a minute.
TODD KERPELMAN: Actually it's
too bad because we were-- that
was when we were just getting
into the interesting
discussions and we can--
we'll bring that back--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah,
I think we should.
TODD KERPELMAN: --for the
beginning of this talk of,
basically, how do you prevent,
particularly, in a JavaScript
kind of game, how do you prevent
clients from cheating?
How do you prevent someone from,
basically, putting in a
little break point in Chrome and
changing things around and
sort of screwing around
with your game code?
And I think where we netted out
that last time was, you
really can't.
That's--
WOLFF DOBSON: Well it doesn't
on what you think is
compromisable and
what you don't.
Ultimately, any client
is compromisable.
If it's sitting on somebody's
desk they're going to be able
to change it.
There are famous examples of in
Halo where they were using
bridges to run the ethernet
packets through.
And then they were intercepting
packets and
changing them or reading them.
They were--
they eventually--
I think they had to run
around and find delay.
And then accuse people-- it's
like, oh you have too much
delay and lag, you must be using
one of these lag cheat
fixer things.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So
this was done on
the server side though?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well no.
So people, because the
old Halo had ran--
the servers were on
people's boxes.
Like they had--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, P2P.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
So in the P2P people put bridges
and their PC would
actually catch incoming packets
and change the and
send them back out again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's ingenius.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're
looking terrifying.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh my gosh.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're
looking terrified.
TODD KERPELMAN: That's--
WOLFF DOBSON: They
can do that.
TODD KERPELMAN: The amount
of effort that is put in.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hey.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah?
WOLFF DOBSON: Do you want
to win at Halo?
I want to win at Halo.
TODD KERPELMAN: Apparently
not that badly.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's a
competitive sport.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Well it sort of is.
I mean--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't know.
WOLFF DOBSON: If 13-year-olds
shouting at you over the
internet, you want
to beat them.
TODD KERPELMAN: But I think
even if there's no kind of
mess around with network
packets, you have the issue of
guys like Colt making auto
players for games that play
them perfectly.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
That got cut off of
the last chat.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
did get cut off.
COLT MCANLIS: I guess I
should fill you in.
So at the end of last chat they
were talking about what
are we playing right now.
I had to admit that I've been
become slightly addicted to
Triple Town a while ago.
TODD KERPELMAN: Which
is an awesome game.
COLT MCANLIS: Fantastic game.
And I kind of realized that
there was algorithmic
properties of it.
A little bit towards the
middle of my addiction.
And decided to actually write
a algorithm that would play
the game for me.
Right?
Because there's a basic pattern
of match three, get an
upgrade, match three,
get an upgrade.
And so I found this algorithmic
pattern and
actually wrote an AI that would
actually play the thing
for me, and actually find
the proper places to put
everything to maximize
the number of castles
on my four by four.
WOLFF DOBSON: Because, you know,
if you have fun, you
need to optimize it out.
That's what I'm saying.
COLT MCANLIS: To me it was an
algorithmic challenge, right.
I mean once you kind of get to
the point you've got the
algorithm together then I
actually stopped caring,
because I was like I solved this
and then one day I woke
up in the morning and I was
like, wait a minute.
It works on a 16 by 16.
But what if it was like a
million by a million?
And so then I actually had to
re-engineer the algorithm to
run everything in JavaScript
to try to find how many
castles I could put in a million
by a million and then
have that data.
WOLFF DOBSON: Did you use
Google Compute Engine?
COLT MCANLIS: I didn't.
WOLFF DOBSON: Its
700,000 cores.
COLT MCANLIS: I should have.
I really should have.
That's next, actually.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
Use all of Google's
infrastructure to be one giant
Triple Town.
TODD KERPELMAN: That,
that would be cool.
COLT MCANLIS: I hate
those bears.
TODD KERPELMAN: The
bears are--
WOLFF DOBSON: We have bears
lose on the internet.
TODD KERPELMAN: They--
yeah, the bears are
frustrating.
WOLFF DOBSON: I love
the bears.
They're so cute.
TODD KERPELMAN: Really?
TODD KERPELMAN: The
ninja bears.
You just can't plane for them
and I have no defense against
them beyond--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh,
they're so cute.
TODD KERPELMAN: --saving the
bots for the times that the
bears, the ninja bears
do come up.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Coming
back to cheating.
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm sorry.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think the
message here is that, like
there's always been cheating if
you go back to the earliest
video game consoles, there's
been mechanisms to cheat and
inflate your score.
So social pressures and server
checks can go a long way.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I think that's really you're
only-- especially in
situations like Colt where you
can't really detect between a
player who just happens to be
really good and an algorithm.
At some point you're going to
know if you say, hey, anyone
that gets higher than this
score is going to be a
cheater, you will probably get
some of those cheaters, but
you're also going to get one or
two legitimate players who
are probably your biggest fans
who have probably put money in
your game, and all of
sudden you've banned
them for being cheaters.
And all the cheaters are going
to do is when you say, hey, a
million points or more you must
be cheater, they're going
to set their games to
play to 900,999.
And you're going to kind of keep
going back and forth in
this sort of arms race
that never ends.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
And I think one of things we
mentioned last time, which
probably didn't make it into
the broadcast, was
one, if you look at--
oh, shoot.
Space Camp.
If you look at Space Camp
and whenever which--
this is what we said last time,
oh my gosh, Space Camp.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So good.
COLT MCANLIS: Go buy
Space Camp now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Play
Space Camp.
COLT MCANLIS: We'll wait.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, exactly.
Hit pause, go download Space
Camp, come back.
One of the things that Space
Camp that's really neat is
that they have a graph that you
get at the end of each one
of your plays that gives you a
histogram on where you are in
relationship to other people
who have done that level.
And what it does is it gives
you a chance to--
it gives you, sorry we
just got ourselves a
bit slightly delayed.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's weird.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm like,
weird looking at me.
It's
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Great.
WOLFF DOBSON: There we go.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
very delayed.
WOLFF DOBSON: So it gives
you this histogram.
And the histogram
allows you to--
OK, we probably--
can we--
TODD KERPELMAN: It's a
little distracting.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
COLT MCANLIS: Look
at the camera.
You're supposed to look
WOLFF DOBSON: I know.
I'm looking at the camera.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
I'm drinking.
Wait.
No I'm not.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's move on.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sorry.
There's a histogram and the
histogram tells you are you
doing well relative
to other people.
So it's not a high score
list where cheaters
are going to win.
All it really tells you is,
I'm doing pretty well or I
should go back and do this again
to see if it's better.
And I think that is absolutely
cool beyond the fact that
Space Camp is really cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
It really changes the high
score table from being an
absolute measurement to being
a relative measurement.
Which cheaters can still skew.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
But that's going to
happen anyway.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: And
I'm all about the
social leader boards.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: A global leader
board, it's going to be
full of cheaters and it's just
going to frustrate anyone that
looks at it.
But a social leader board if
you've got one guy, life Colt,
that's at the top who--
COLT MCANLIS: I like
how we keep
calling it the Colt situation.
Like this guy over here.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The cheater.
COLT MCANLIS: The cheater.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, exactly.
The cheater.
COLT MCANLIS: It was
an algorithm.
I'm a programmer.
I program.
That's what I do.
TODD KERPELMAN: And I might
remove you from my gamers
circles or something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No, but global
leader boards are incredibly
frustrating.
Especially for me who maybe
is not the best
at some games but--
WOLFF DOBSON: Maybe you need to
join one of those StarCraft
teams that can click more than
2,000 times per second.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: When I look at
the high score table and I see
that I am 250,000 down the
list it's discouraging.
WOLFF DOBSON: There is some
argument that this is part of
what killed arcades
that you went to.
There were a lot of things
that were pushing on the
arcades in the '80s
and '90s that--
where people want to
play and gather--
but part of it is that they
network the high score lists.
And all a sudden like three guys
in Seattle were the only
people who were getting on the
high score list anywhere.
And everybody else was
like, why am I even
playing this game?
But when it was-- you'd go down
there and you'd see seven
people you didn't really know,
but they were all the people
who played Street Fighter at
lunch on Thursdays and then
you had somebody to play with.
And there was a local ranking
that you could beat.
But as soon as there
was this other--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I guess I missed
the networking of high
score tables.
You couldn't just unplug the
box and plug it back in?
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah, exactly.
COLT MCANLIS: See.
He's cheater too.
Not just me.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm just
leveling the playing field.
COLT MCANLIS: It's all
the NaCl guys.
WOLFF DOBSON: The social
people just want
us all to get along.
COLT MCANLIS: The NaCl guys
are just aggressive.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
TODD KERPELMAN: So, anyway,
let's move on.
Let's--
so I think that kind of pretty
much caught up where
we were last time.
We talked a little bit about
what games we were playing,
but we can talk about
that later.
We never really talked too much
about game related apps
and hang outs.
One most interesting I think
has been Tabletop Forge.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: Which is, I
guess, not so much a game
itself as a--
WOLFF DOBSON: As a platform
for playing games on.
Yeah.
It's really neat.
They have a wonderful story
that goes with it too.
Where they--
they were two guys who were in
different places who working
together, who were working
separately, on apps that would
sort of support playing Dungeons
and Dragons and other
RPGs in Hangouts.
And then they sort of realized
on the internet, oh, hey,
we're working on the same thing,
we should join forces.
So they joined forces and people
really twigged to it.
And then they ran
a Kickstarter.
And they were like, hey, if
you guys gave us a little
money we could really
make this good.
And the Kickstarter went big
and then eventually got on
Penny Arcade, which just
exploded after that.
And they're out there.
If you look for Tabletop Forge
on Google+ they've got their
own page, you can download
the app.
I think they're still running
a new kick starter for even
more features.
And you get cool custom tiles
and stuff if you--
but that I think is
really exciting.
And I think it's a neat way to
use Hangouts because, as we're
talking about cheating,
cheating in
RPGs is sort of silly.
To be like, I have a plus--
TODD KERPELMAN: I'm 120!
WOLFF DOBSON: --175 sword.
But within Hangouts you have
social pressure to sort of
keep it reasonable.
The people you're playing with,
your friends, are going
to hold you in into playing
in a legitimate way.
I think that's neat too.
I'm really excited about it.
I have friends that I role
play with, but incredibly
rarely, because we're not
co-located very well.
COLT MCANLIS: Are you the
lightning bolt guy?
WOLFF DOBSON: Lightning bolt.
Fruit.
No.
No, I'm just, I'm a
reluctant paladin.
I've been chosen by the gods
and I really don't want the
responsibility.
It's not unlike my real life.
So, yeah, that's what's
going on there.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hopefully there's
going to be all kinds
of new stuff.
We have 8 Ball Pool and a few
other things that are playable
now that you should check out.
COLT MCANLIS: So you brought up
an interesting point there,
and I want to get the panel's
view on this.
There's actually been a pretty
healthy trend lately for both
professional and amateur game
developers coming out on
Kickstarter and asking for--
putting up a game plan, putting
a business decision,
actually asking for money
to move forward with.
This has got a lot
of attention.
More attention than some
people ever estimated.
In fact, Gabe Newell came out
a while ago, before this
phenomenon, came out and
actually mentioned that he
believes one of the future ways
to do game development
may be consumer funded.
So the question for you guys is,
how big of an ecosystem do
you see this?
How long do you see
the tail on this?
Do you actually see
this happening?
I haven't really seen any
of the games come out.
I haven't seen, besides the guys
over at Double Fine, I
haven't really seen a lot of
established game developers
coming out and using
this medium.
What are guys' thoughts
on this?
WOLFF DOBSON: Well I think one
of the big pieces of news was
Penny Arcade, not to bring them
up again, but they just
had a Kickstarter saying hey,
let's work on the stuff that
we want to work on and get rid
of ads off the front page.
And they didn't quite make it.
They got enough money, they
said, I think yesterday, they
got enough money to remove the
top ad from their thing.
And then they're still probably
going to do the
project they were kickstarting
even though they didn't quite
reach their goal to do it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The Lookouts.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
The Daughters of the Forest
I think [INAUDIBLE].
COLT MCANLIS: Which is cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: Which is cool.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
super-cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: But, yeah, that's
been an interesting
phenomenon.
There's the Leisure Suit Larry
guys who are rebooting Leisure
Suit Larry using Kickstarter.
COLT MCANLIS: So, but I
mean, do you think--
so here's a problem right.
You get a lot of developers and
you can come in and the
way, my understanding of the
way Kickstarter works is,
effectively, this money is sort
of pledged to you ahead
of time and then you're
kind of given this--
I'm not sure what the
restrictions are versus the
lending company to you as an
individual and where the money
goes, but effectively there's
not a lot of checks and
balances involved as
far as product
management is concerned.
To assure the product actually
reaches the public.
That you're actually
going to do it.
You don't get a-- it's not like
having a VC-funded system
where you get some dude sitting
in you cubicle--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
As consumers we don't end
up on their board.
I think is what you're saying.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah, exactly.
We really have no ability to
hold them liable for our
potential investment.
Right?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Personally I've
been very skeptical of
most Kickstarter projects.
There's been a few that
I've been tempted by.
I'm like, oh, if this actually
came out I would
buy it in an instant.
And I've always just decided,
well, when it does come out, I
will buy it.
And avoid the risk.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well
when I was--
I just had back surgery recently
and when I was on the
painkillers I went
to Kickstarter
and did some damage.
COLT MCANLIS: I'm sorry buddy,
that sounds like a new
advertising campaign
for [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
COLT MCANLIS: On painkillers?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
WOLFF DOBSON: Painkillers
and Kickstarter.
Perfect together.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Post-surgery?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Check us out.
TODD KERPELMAN: I guess I--
COLT MCANLIS: I think you just
closed the thread on this one.
What's your thoughts
on Kickstarter?
Well, take some quaaludes.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
On industrial painkillers,
horse
tranquilizer, it works great.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There has been a
few projects that seems very
tempting to me, but I've read
some pretty rough postmortems
of people who've got Kickstarter
money and promised
too many gifts and freebies to
the donators and ended up,
after collecting a few hundred
thousand dollars, ended up
with $20,000 to actually
build the game with.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
I've actually heard that, and
some of the products that I've
supported have, they've
sort of admitted that.
I think we went a little
crazy with the gifts.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
And lawyer fees and taxes.
There's a lot of things that
people aren't factoring in,
and so maybe it's the developers
responsibility to
kind of educate them as to what
percentage of Kickstarter
money are they actually
going to end up with.
COLT MCANLIS: And I think, to
be very modern about this
stuff, I think that's where a
lot of criticism comes for the
new OUYA console is OK, fine.
So you've made x amount
of money.
Cut that in half and that's
actually what you're going to
walk away with in
terms of taxes.
Right?
And then how many of that
is going to produce
in number of units.
There's manufacturing
costs, there's
all these other things.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
FCC licensing, all
that kind of stuff.
COLT MCANLIS: Exactly.
There's a massive amount of
money overhead that's not
being accounted for.
So now Double Fine I think did
a great job with this too.
Is they've already come out
and said, hey, Kickstarter
wasn't our only funding.
They kind of used that as their
springboard to then go
get funding from other people.
And, now, if OUYA is going that
route, I think that's
very valuable.
But it's a perfect example of
hey, we're only going to have
enough money to make 1,000
units the first batch.
Right?
And then trying to talk to game
developers about hey,
let's get you on 1,000 units and
get that out to the people
so you can make money.
That's a really difficult
discussion.
TODD KERPELMAN: It does help
solve some of the traction
problem, right.
Of like--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: --no one wants
to give you money until you've
demonstrated traction.
And you can't really demonstrate
traction until
you've spent a bunch of time
building product, which you
can't do because you have no
money because no one will give
it to you because you
don't have traction.
So I think Kickstarter can
be really useful for
demonstrating there's at least
100,000 people out there who
have been willing to give me
$10 to get an early preview
copy of this game.
So clearly there's some sort
of market for this.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Maybe if we
took the name of the site
literally as a kick starter.
Maybe it's doing its
job right there.
Right?
Giving projects some legs, so
that they can go out and get a
significant amount of money.
TODD KERPELMAN: But not the site
that you should go to to
fully fund your project.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: It could be.
COLT MCANLIS: So really the four
of us need to make a post
Kickstarter site where, once
you've got your Kickstarter
money, you come to us and we'll
give you VC capital and
then you can go the
rest of the way.
And then that'll get the angry
guys sitting in your cubicle
ensuring that you'll
hit your milestone.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The 1,000
console, sorry
1,000 units, right?
That's not enough.
The number that I've always
heard is six million.
Six million is enough to get
video game publishers
interested in producing content
for your platform.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, so you're
talking about the buy-in.
I thought, six million
copies of the game?
Holy moly!
That would be awesome.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No.
Six million pieces of hardware
before it becomes relevant to
large publishers--
TODD KERPELMAN: I mean, I think
if we're talking about
the OUYA specifically, or--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
TODD KERPELMAN: I thought
it was oooya.
I mean, you know--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's all vowels.
TODD KERPELMAN: That, my
impression of it is that, you
don't have to essentially build
a new game from scratch.
There are some modifications
you make to a game that's
available on Android.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Sure.
Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: And you--
to take advantage of the new
interface and the actual--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Controller.
TODD KERPELMAN: --controller
and all that.
It's not like, oh, OK, now I'm
building for a PlayStation 3.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yeah.
Well, and PlayStation 3 has
pretty heavy technical debt
that you have to go into.
TODD KERPELMAN: The other
thing I will say about
Kickstarter is that I think
it's interesting that--
and maybe it's just because this
is all the news I read--
but I think it's interesting
that most the projects that
seemed to have been successful,
or at least gotten
the most funding, or have taken
off have all been games
related, for the most part.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I think one
of the other ones that's
been pretty successful
is hardware.
There's the Watch guys and OUYA
and things like this.
TODD KERPELMAN: The
gaming VR device.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah
TODD KERPELMAN: That
think looks cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: It
does look cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah
it does look cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm like him.
As soon as they have one.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
I'll jump on it as soon
as it's for sale.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
I can tell a story where
I there was--
I think there's one other
emotional moment where
Kickstarter can be good.
And that's where you as a fan
are putting your money down to
say like, I really want this.
I think that's like Double Fine
saying, I want point and
click adventures again,
or whatever, however
they phrased it.
Or an album.
I'm $10 into this album.
I did a Kickstarter
for MC Frontalot.
I was like, I want--
I have been listening to your
music for free for so long, if
there's some way I can give you
$5, $10, $15 I'm there.
And I put my money down and I
got my early access to videos.
I felt like a good fan.
And it was really fun.
I was really tempted
to do the--
one of the rewards was you can
spend thousands of dollars and
he'll show up in your
living room and rap.
Which I thought that would have
been pretty awesome too.
COLT MCANLIS: Was this on the
painkillers or off the
painkillers?
WOLFF DOBSON: This is well
before the painkillers.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
OK.
I got to make sure I understand
where the
conversation is going to.
WOLFF DOBSON: No, no.
MC Frontalot is great.
And actually I don't know if
you guys remember-- this is
going to date me a little bit--
there's a game called
Fool's Errand.
Anybody remember that?
It was on the old puzzle game
that came out on the Mac.
It was on the Mac Plus.
I played it when I was
in high school.
It was incredibly,
incredibly old.
It was brilliant.
It was all these little puzzles
stuck together and you
sort of assembled into
some big meta puzzle
that you had to solve.
And we spent hours playing
this game.
And of course we pirated it
because we were high school
and college students--
and--
TODD KERPELMAN: Which
we do not endorse.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well,
here's the thing.
So I felt really guilty about
it because I had so much--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Here comes
the endorsement.
WOLFF DOBSON: I had so
much fun with it.
I had so much with the game and
Cliff Johnson, who's the
guy who I searched for him with
Google at one point, and
I came across this site.
And it turns out he's actually
making a sequel called A Fool
and His Money.
And there's all these auction
games built into it, as well
as all his regular puzzles.
And he was soliciting
pre-sales.
This was before Kickstarter.
This was five years ago.
Soliciting pre-sales.
And he was like, it's
going to be whatever
it is, $29 or whatever.
And I was like, sign me up.
I owe you this money from so
long ago, with interest.
This is great.
I put my money down.
I realize there's some irony
in a game called The
Fool and His Money.
This is the game that I put
down money in advance on.
I have not seen that game yet.
But I don't care.
Because as a fan I felt
like I was supporting.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The
guy is amazing.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's brilliant.
COLT MCANLIS: He
just went meta.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Yeah, exactly.
It's some kind of
performance art.
He sends this email about once
every six months saying,
really soon now.
Really, really soon now.
I'm still looking
forward to it.
COLT MCANLIS: A guy in Nigeria
sends me those emails.
About once a month.
WOLFF DOBSON: Have you
finally gotten your
transfer of a $150,000?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: No,
but it's soon.
WOLFF DOBSON: Directly
into your account.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's really,
really soon.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: The government's
sanctioning it.
That's the problem.
We got some time left for
questions, right?
TODD KERPELMAN: We do.
And I think, depending on how
long we want to run--
we never actually determined if
this is a half hour or 45
minute show.
COLT MCANLIS: Should we ask
that guy over there?
TODD KERPELMAN: We
left it vague--
COLT MCANLIS: Let's
keep going.
TODD KERPELMAN: --so
that we can.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, I think
we need to keep going.
I want to talk about games
we've been playing.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: I want
to talk about--
I just want on vacation with
my Nexus 7, and I--
COLT MCANLIS: To Alaska.
WOLFF DOBSON: To Alaska.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh,
that's right.
WOLFF DOBSON: That--
there was some unfortunate
moose comment.
I did in fact see a moose.
I saw a moose.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: WiFi hotspot?
WOLFF DOBSON: It was
not a WiFi hotspot.
I was in the middle of Denali
where there was not even a
call signal.
And, in fact, I had trouble.
There's some kind of wacky
WiFi in Alaska.
But once--
it turned out the coffee shops
and, weirdly, the little tiny
hole in the wall places in
Denali, awesome WiFi.
I brought my Nexus 7 and I
basically, I didn't bring my
laptop or anything else,
it was like my entire
entertainment device,
was my Nexus 7.
And I wanted to talk about one
of the games that my daughter
and I just went nuts over.
It was Super Stickman Golf.
I don't know if you guys
have seen that.
It's by Noodlecake Studios.
It is just a wonderful
take on 2-D golf.
It's all platforms and
you're bouncing the
ball up off the platforms.
TODD KERPELMAN: Oh.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh, cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: Really clever.
They switch to a free model and
they have a micro payments
where you can buy power
ups in the thing.
It's a little weird because, I
love this game and you should
all play it, but at the same
time, like a fan, I want to
put my money down, but I don't
really want to buy power ups.
I just want it to be fair.
So, there's an interesting
emotional thing.
So I'm going to buy some power
ups when I get to the point
which I need them.
But it is an interesting
case where I was just
like, I'm a big fan.
Here, $5, $10 whatever
you want.
But instead I'm going to micro
payment my way to--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So is that
game available on--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's available
on Android.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All
Android devices?
WOLFF DOBSON: I believe it's
all Android devices.
I'll look right now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's great.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
It's really great.
I would-- ooh, I haven't
plus one'd yet.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Going to have
to get it for my phone.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
I would definitely
recommend it.
And it's wonderful
on a tablet.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Great.
COLT MCANLIS: Especially
the Nexus 7.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Especially
your Nexus 7.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The Nexus 7.
TODD KERPELMAN: John, what
are you playing?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Let's see.
Lately I've been playing Super
Mario 3D Land actually.
On my 3DS.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm enjoying
that quite a bit.
And, I know this is going to
be unpopular, but Scramble
with Friends.
WOLFF DOBSON: Scramble
with Friends?
I'm still playing Draw
with Friends.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or,
Draw Something.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Draw
Something.
WOLFF DOBSON: Draw Something.
TODD KERPELMAN: Draw
Something?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Scramble with
Friends I can't stop playing.
I'm too competitive.
I have some really
good competition.
WOLFF DOBSON: Did you write an
algorithm using Google Compute
Engine to cheat?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You know how
many times I've been tempted
to just, to go ahead
and do that?
COLT MCANLIS: See.
See.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'm like, OK,
I can just pause this,
transcribe the board onto the
computer and solve it.
And just dominate.
But I want it to be fair.
TODD KERPELMAN: Because are you
actually playing with real
life friends?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're not
playing with robots.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Playing with my
cousin and old friends from
high school.
I don't want to--
TODD KERPELMAN: You don't
want to cheat.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Exactly.
COLT MCANLIS: Wait.
You don't want to cheat?
Playing with your old friends
from high school?
WOLFF DOBSON: I think that's
exactly the moment
which you do cheat.
COLT MCANLIS: That's
the exact people.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
No.
COLT MCANLIS: You do cheat all
the way up until the high
school convention.
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm sorry old
friends from high school.
COLT MCANLIS: Or the reunion.
Right?
Then you have something to talk
about at the convention.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I just
kill at Scramble.
Perfect games.
I don't know how I do it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh, and also
speaking of puzzle games.
I also played 100 Floors.
That sort of--
COLT MCANLIS: How is that?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's got some
ridiculous number of downloads
on the Play store.
What are they at?
They're like 10 million
or something.
Crazy.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: How does
the game work?
WOLFF DOBSON: It is sort of
an escape classic 2005
escape the room game.
Where you just kind of have an
interface and you kind of
click around until you
figure it out.
Sometimes--
and it's just, again, it's
like Fool's Errand.
It's this collection of puzzles
and you don't really
know-- each time you look at,
what am I going to do?
Is it motion sensors?
Am I clicking on things?
Is there a code?
And they're--
it does lie a little.
There are only 90 floors
right now.
But it was very disappointing
when I got to 90 and it said,
more coming soon.
Nooo!
COLT MCANLIS: That's
how they get you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: 90 floors just
didn't have the same ring.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: But it's great.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
100 [INAUDIBLE].
Never mind.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Speaking of--
WOLFF DOBSON: If
you have only.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: --old
puzzle games.
Well, kind of new
I don't know if anyone
played Zack & Wiki?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: For the Wii?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Man,
that game was good.
WOLFF DOBSON: That was fun.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I wish that--
we need to start a Kickstarter
to get
Capcom to make a sequel.
COLT MCANLIS: I'll put up
the post-Kickstarter--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: All right.
COLT MCANLIS: --website
for that.
WOLFF DOBSON: You're there.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I wonder
if Kickstarter will
allow you to do that.
To take someone else's
intellectual property and make
a Kickstarter to create a
sequel for that game.
Probably not.
WOLFF DOBSON: Wasn't there a
thing where there was the
Flash game that was all the
classic Nintendo and SNES
characters, and then it got
popular enough that they were
like, oh, we should actually
release this as a
downloadable game.
At which point all the
intellectual property stuff
was a problem.
So they now have characters who
are a lot like, but not
quite, [INAUDIBLE]
for these things.
So, yeah, you can do that.
You could have like
Mack and Ricky.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Mack
and Ricky.
WOLFF DOBSON: Something
like that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right, Colt,
what are you playing?
TODD KERPELMAN: What
are you playing?
COLT MCANLIS: I'm actually, with
the hype for the new Team
Fortress 2, Man vs. Machine, I'm
actually getting back into
Team Fortress 2.
I used to do a lot of
competitive first person
shooter gaming back in my
day when I was younger.
And I'm actually getting back
into Team Fortress 2.
I thought it was a really--
I love TF2.
I love the way they came
out with a style.
They changed it.
They put a lot of atmosphere,
a lot of character into it.
It was a huge departure
from the other FPSs
we've seen at the time.
We're starting-- there was
kind of that period where
everything, every first person
shooter came out with that
gray tint to it.
They came out with bright, vivid
colors, great emotion.
I thought it was fantastic.
It's really fun to get
back into it now that
it's free to play.
It's really cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I keep almost
getting back into it.
I'm just--
I should install this.
It's so much fun.
COLT MCANLIS: It is.
It really is.
And, plus, there's Valve is
adding the robots so we don't
have to write our own now.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: There you go.
Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and
you need a hat.
COLT MCANLIS: The sandwich.
The sandwich.
WOLFF DOBSON: I always think
that game is just an absolute
triumph of character design.
Among all of the things, I think
they said they wanted to
look like a Winslow
Homer painting.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: And it
really-- it's--
I went to downtown San Jose
while they were having and
Fanime, which is the big
anime convention.
And they were also having
graduation for San Jose State,
which meant that it was a really
weird group of people
all mixing together.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Lot
of cosplay.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
There's the thing.
There was all these people
dressed as cosplay, and all
these other people dressed in
their Sunday best all walking
through each other and giving
each other these-- what are
you doing here?
And it was interesting that
when I was walking through
there there was tons of Team
Fortress despite the fact that
that's not even anime at all.
It's just those characters
are so iconic that they
wanted to do it.
COLT MCANLIS: What
about you Todd?
What do you play?
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's see.
Haven't had a lot of time
to play games the
last week or so.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh,
that's right.
You have the new--
TODD KERPELMAN: Got
the new baby.
COLT MCANLIS: You've cloned.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I don't remember--
WOLFF DOBSON: It's like
a video game.
And there are a lot
of micro payments.
That's what I'm saying.
COLT MCANLIS: For the
next 20 years.
TODD KERPELMAN: And there's
a lot of crying.
COLT MCANLIS: It's like an
old school NES game.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Extremely
difficult and lots of crying.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yep.
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
Got to be careful you
don't mess up.
I did--
in between all of that, I did,
finally, I defeated Diablo my
first run through on--
COLT MCANLIS: Diablo 3.
TODD KERPELMAN: --Diablo 3.
WOLFF DOBSON: You finally
beat Diablo 1.
Congratulations.
TODD KERPELMAN: No.
Diablo 3.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Where
did you find DOS?
COLT MCANLIS: There's a
Kickstarter project for it
apparently.
TODD KERPELMAN: Want to go back
and kind of replay it
with either a different
character, or the next
difficulty level, but at the
same time, given my limited
time for gaming at the moment I
said, I should try something
completely different.
And so I have actually have
now installed Skyrim.
And I think I played--
actually I played about two
hours of trying to decide
which mods I want to install
and 1/2 an hour of actually
game playing.
WOLFF DOBSON: And at
least 15 minutes of
tweaking the settings.
A little shinier, no a
little less shiny.
A little more, little less.
TODD KERPELMAN: The mods totally
appeal to my geeky
side of oh, I could get better
looking eyebrows on people.
But then there's five different
versions of the
eyebrow variation mod
and I start to--
WOLFF DOBSON: See, I'm having
flashbacks to playing Mass
Effect where each Mass Effect
game I had to start four times
because I kept revising how I
wanted my character to look.
In Mass Effect 3 I got
way into it and I was
like, I love this.
I had my tough thing.
And then I realized suddenly
that she looked weirdly like
Michael Jackson.
I was like, ahhh!
I had to stop and restart
the game again.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Can you
moonwalk in that game?
WOLFF DOBSON: That character
would have been able to--
TODD KERPELMAN: Only if they
were in animation.
WOLFF DOBSON: There's a perk
in there that you can buy.
TODD KERPELMAN: I always kind
of felt like game developers
all need to get together and
work on a common standard for
facial construction.
Every game, Saints Row,
and Mass Effect, and
Skyrim, and all these.
There's--
WOLFF DOBSON: Tiger
Woods Golf.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
There's 80 different sliders
how you can get
your character look.
And depending on how I'm feeling
I either try and make
them look as close to me as
possible, or as close to some
famous person or something.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was just going
to say, it depends on what's
going to happen to them.
Whether I make them look
like Todd or want them
to look like me.
Oh, sorry.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: The most
grotesque character you
possibly can.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's what
The Sims is for.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Move all the
sliders to the right.
TODD KERPELMAN: But then it
would be great if I could keep
that character designed from
one game to the next.
So I don't have to recreate me
our Jason Statham or whatever.
And Tiger Woods.
WOLFF DOBSON: Jason Statham.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would be awesome.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Tiger,
let's go.
WOLFF DOBSON: Or in my case,
weirdly, Michael Jackson.
How did I do that?
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Every game.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
Well, is that what we
have time for today?
TODD KERPELMAN: Actually we do
have time for questions now.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh my gosh.
We didn't even answer
our questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: I know.
All right.
So we've got a few questions.
And the first one is,
[INAUDIBLE]--
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh my gosh.
Look at all these questions.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah,
we do have
quite a number of questions.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh wow.
TODD KERPELMAN: And, in fact,
maybe I should reload and make
sure that--
COLT MCANLIS: There's no
new question on top.
TODD KERPELMAN: --there's
not a question.
Because--
11 questions.
That's--
WOLFF DOBSON: You actually
have to click that.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
That's 10 more than I think
we had last time.
WOLFF DOBSON: It's almost
like somebody knew
we were doing this.
TODD KERPELMAN: Can we talk
a little bit about cross
platform convergence between
Chrome Web Store an Android
via a unifying login experience
for players
actually creating unified
app ID across platforms.
I don't know if there's
a whole lot we
can really talk about.
Let me see.
I guess part of it really
depends on do we see, at some
point, games in the browser,
games on your tablet.
Are they going to be the same?
I know this was sort of an issue
with a lot of the social
game developers.
Is they had these very popular
social games, tried to,
essentially, take them as is on
to mobile devices and found
that they just weren't
nearly as successful.
And it was these companies that
basically created games
from scratch on mobile devices
that were actually--
very similar kind of Sim
building games that ended up
being successful.
Just because, even though the
games are similar, the play
patterns and styles and the
amount of time you dedicate to
playing a game on your phone,
versus playing a game on a
tablet, versus playing a game
on a browser, is all just
slightly different enough that
it's really hard to have the
same game experience across
multiple devices.
Even though--
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, and also,
there are lots of little tiny
things when you're doing
development across platform.
Like start-up time.
A mobile game, given the
compressed time people are
going to be playing it, they're
not going to be like,
I'm going to click this, go
read, read it, and then come
back and it'll be loaded.
So just doing the straight
ports that way
sometimes can be--
just doesn't work.
Loading time, screen usage, real
estate, all that stuff.
Yeah.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
said, yeah.
I think unifying login,
that would be nice.
WOLFF DOBSON: That
would be cool.
You should all use OAuth2.
TODD KERPELMAN: That
would totally help.
And did I hear that the
standard has been--
WOLFF DOBSON: They're looking
for an RFC now.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh wow.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
COLT MCANLIS: Very cool.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Cool.
TODD KERPELMAN: That-- so what
that actually means is that
it's going to be considered more
official than I guess it
has been in the past.
WOLFF DOBSON: The way it is
now, which is sort of
official, it'll now be
sort of official.
COLT MCANLIS: Well I thought the
word Auth in OAuth meant
authoritative.
Is that--
is that not right?
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Not exactly.
It did in version 10, but
not inversion 16 or 21.
COLT MCANLIS: Oh, you
got to update your--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
Exactly.
COLT MCANLIS: --client
side handling.
TODD KERPELMAN: This
is a good question.
I love the idea of
Native Client.
WOLFF DOBSON: Native Client?
What's that?
TODD KERPELMAN: Have you
considered creating a special
section in the Chrome Web Store
to just show apps that
use Native Client to more
widely promote it's use?
COLT MCANLIS: Interesting.
First off, thank you
for the love.
Native Client's fantastic
technology.
We all love it here and embrace
it quite heartily.
We haven't specifically called
out Native Client in the
Chrome Web Store, simply because
we don't really feel
that there's-- so Chrome Web
Store is a consumer driven
place, right.
And so most people coming to
Chrome Web Store are looking
for a genre or a character
type or
something along those lines.
They're not really looking for--
hey, show me the best
HTML 5 game.
WOLFF DOBSON: We go into the
store looking for that.
COLT MCANLIS: Right.
Right.
And, quite frankly, that
does occur but we
are quite the minority.
If you are looking for a great
collection of Native Client
titles, though, you can actually
go to the Native
Client website.
We actually have a list of all
of them that we're aware of.
Gonacl.com.
That's G-O-N-A-C-L.com.
And if you look on the sidebar
there's actually a little
community section down there
that has a list of
applications in the
Chrome Web Store.
And they're great games.
You should go check them out.
And--
WOLFF DOBSON: I'm
doing right now.
My goodness.
There is one.
COLT MCANLIS: Can we screen
cap from his machine?
WOLFF DOBSON: I'll just kind of
turn around and pull it up.
COLT MCANLIS: Definitely
check those out.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's see.
I'm actually going to skip
down to-- someone had a--
speaking of cheating, can you
discuss the role of future
cheat-proof games such that
every move is in the open and
subject to review by everyone,
like Tic-Tac-Toe or chess.
COLT MCANLIS: Wow.
So I have an opinion on this.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: Shockingly.
WOLFF DOBSON: Not like normal.
COLT MCANLIS: Not like normal.
Right?
Where I keep to myself.
I not too sure about that.
You're effectively crowd
sourcing games.
This will only work for a
certain type of things, right?
In addition to that, it's going
to slow down game play
significantly.
There was a big hubbub when the
NFL and the Major League
Baseball added instant
replay review and
those sorts of things.
Everyone's big criticism is it's
going to slow the game
down anymore.
Right?
And they added all these
other features.
You can only do so many,
they cost you
timeouts and other stuff.
But still it's--
in video games it's a little
bit different, right?
It's a digital medium.
There's millions of people
playing concurrent
games all the time.
Maybe if you had some way where
I play a move and then I
check someone else's move?
I don't know.
It doesn't seem worth
the risk.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
I--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And also, how
does that stop cheating?
If I'm playing chess with
someone couldn't I have a
chess simulation running
alongside?
WOLFF DOBSON: It's a different
kind of cheating then what I
think Alan is talking about
here, which is much more I
make a move and then if
everybody accepts that was a
true we can keep going.
I think it's more, it would be
more implemented negatively,
which is, that looks
like it's a lie.
And--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
too good of a move.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, no, it's
more like in chess.
Like, hey, your queen
just teleported.
This-- if you ever Pirateer
the board game, it was
actually in the rules
that cheating was
part of this game.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Because
you're pirates.
WOLFF DOBSON: Knocking the drink
over and then moving all
the pieces around.
Yeah, and there's also the sense
of being able to roll
back games and look
for cheats later.
And verify that they're
actually true.
So in real time you
leave it alone.
But then when you post hoc, if
somebody challenges it, you
can review them.
And automated review and
things like that.
It's a little bit like
the way the--
when you go in and get
a document notarized.
It doesn't make it any safer
to notarize it but it means
that when you go backwards and
somebody challenges something
the notarization says
this document was
true at this time.
So, yeah, definitely something
like that would be
interesting.
It's also a way people identify
cheaters or griefers.
Just being able to say I enjoyed
playing with this
person, I did not enjoy playing
with this person.
And then if somebody gets
too many of these--
that can be gamed pretty
heavily though.
COLT MCANLIS: We're going to
be gamed the other way too.
If you make a move and I have
to validate that was and
actual move, and I don't like
your move because it's about
to pwn me, I can grief you and
say, no it's not a good move.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's
too good of a move.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
You're too awesome
at this game--
WOLFF DOBSON: Remind me not
to play chess with you.
COLT MCANLIS: And I
no longer like it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: You just
check-mated me.
That can't be legitimate.
COLT MCANLIS: Possible.
TODD KERPELMAN: I guess the
issue, for me, is there's a
lot of games that are
interesting based on the fact
that there is secret
information.
While Tic-Tac-Toe and chess and
checkers and those sorts
of games there are no secrets,
you'd be cutting off a lot of
interesting games in the
process, just by--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think that's
one of the joys of computer
media and gaming is assuming
that your database can handle
that much writing.
Being able to do all of your
moves on the server is great.
TODD KERPELMAN: Let's see.
We've got two minutes left.
Here's a short question.
When will the NaCl VS plug-in
be available?
COLT MCANLIS: Yes.
We are excited about this.
We're starting to see the first
couple check-ins come
through the tree.
Exciting times are ahead.
We're working out a couple bugs
right now, getting the
documentation set up.
We're expecting to
see it soon.
The developer preview should
come out and the Pepper stable
version, SDK, we're hoping
to land within
another couple weeks.
TODD KERPELMAN: VS here
being Visual Studio.
COLT MCANLIS: Visual Studio.
TODD KERPELMAN: Clarify for--
people wouldn't think it was
versus or something.
WOLFF DOBSON: I just want to
say that I went to the NaCl
Gallery and I was horrified to
discover one of the games was
called Wolf Toss.
COLT MCANLIS: That's actually
a really good game.
WOLFF DOBSON: I bet it
is but, I mean, dude.
TODD KERPELMAN: It's
not about you.
It's not always about you.
WOLFF DOBSON: It is about me.
COLT MCANLIS: I think we should
add a hack to it to put
your face on the wolf.
WOLFF DOBSON: Ahhh!
COLT MCANLIS: We'll
email the authors.
Guys over at [INAUDIBLE], if
you're watching, put his face
on the wolf.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Toss
that wolf.
TODD KERPELMAN: And let's see.
We'll end on this
one question.
Why are games getting easier
and easier year after year?
Why are developers not
creating games
like Baldur's Gate?
Even Witcher was not as hard
as games some years ago.
Do you remember Contra?
WOLFF DOBSON: Contra.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: They still
make Contra games.
Contra 4 just came out
two years ago.
Demon's Souls and Dark Souls--
TODD KERPELMAN: I was going to
say, those were the games you
were playing last time.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I
love those games
because they're so difficult.
So they're still out there,
but you they're not
mainstream.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
I was going to say, the main
answer to that is the
expansion of the audience.
When you get away from people
like me who sit alone in their
basement playing video games and
trying to figure out how
to build a--
you're at a very technical and
very numerically savvy
audience who is going to be min
maxing their heart out at
things like Baldur's Gate.
For when you want have
broad appeal games
like Mass Effect where--
in fact they had a neat, when
you play Mass Effect it
actually gives you an option
in the beginning.
Do you want to play this like
a first person shooter?
Do you want to play this
only for the story?
Or do you want to play
some balance of RPG?
Because they're like, look,
there are all these different
audiences who want to experience
this content.
We're trying to mold it in a way
that makes it so that you
can enjoy it no matter
what you're doing.
COLT MCANLIS: Now, is the ending
different for each?
I might have to send
some more emails.
WOLFF DOBSON: You know what we
need to talk about is the
ending to Mass Effect.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I can
really share the--
who asked that question?
I want to address
them by handle.
TODD KERPELMAN: I
gotta look up.
WOLFF DOBSON: You.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
You are just not playing
the right games.
No.
TODD KERPELMAN: T-O-M-A-S-Z.
Tomasz.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Tomasz.
Tomas Z. I can share your
frustration because I love
brutally difficult games.
But they're still out there.
A new Contra game is coming out
because I pay attention to
Contra games, because I want
to just cry and slam the
system down on the floor.
WOLFF DOBSON: And this is why
they made wireless controllers
so you can throw them.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: It doesn't
pull your entire--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And, I mean,
right now you could--
I have collectively spend
about 250 hours playing
Demon's Souls and Dark Souls.
Go and check it out.
WOLFF DOBSON: The other thing
is that, famously, Nintendo
early on made their games
brutally hard because they
weren't long enough.
And that pipeline
was too short.
The pipeline wasn't
full enough.
They weren't going to be able to
release games fast enough.
The manufacturing process for
cartridges was too difficult.
And so having--
making your games take longer
was just part of the thing.
TODD KERPELMAN: Part
of the padding.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
I went back and started playing
the original Colossal
Cave Adventure game and
it was crazy hard.
Even though I remembered
all the puzzles.
I was sort of like, I
don't know how I--
COLT MCANLIS: No, no.
You want to cry?
And we can close on this
if we need to.
TODD KERPELMAN: OK.
COLT MCANLIS: Go back and play
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
for the NES.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Which one?
COLT MCANLIS: The first one.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I've
beaten that.
COLT MCANLIS: Yeah.
Yeah, once.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I had
that game as a kid
and I mastered it.
WOLFF DOBSON: Next time we do
this we're going to bring this
in and you're going
to play it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I'll play it.
Oh, it's been years.
COLT MCANLIS: I'll try it.
I bought it on the Wii.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: It's brutal.
COLT MCANLIS: It's brutal.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
It hates you.
COLT MCANLIS: Three weeks.
I didn't turn the Wii off--
WOLFF DOBSON: It absolutely
hates you.
COLT MCANLIS: --because I
was used to doing that.
Right.
Couldn't do it.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That stage where
you're going through the
water under the dam and you have
diffuse all the bombs and
the clock is ticking.
WOLFF DOBSON: It is--
COLT MCANLIS: The worst thing
is that if you don't bring
Donatello to the Mouser battle
you're just done.
It's the whole level.
All you're doing is trying to
get rid of Raphael because he
doesn't matter to you.
Just bring Donatello
to the Mouser.
This is insane.
Hardest game ever.
WOLFF DOBSON: But the--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Another really
difficult game that's new is
Super Meat Boy.
That game is brutal.
WOLFF DOBSON: Although
here's the thing with
Super Meat Boy though.
Super Meat Boy is incredibly
difficult.
But Super Meat Boy
is also fair.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: In the sense that,
when you play it, you
can get better at it.
And your deaths are quick.
And the reward for death is
that you get another cool
little animation.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: That's often
what people praise Demon's
Souls and Dark Souls for.
Its brutal but it's fair.
When you die you're not like,
oh this game cheated me.
It's like no, I made
a mistake.
WOLFF DOBSON: I shouldn't
have done that.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's why a lot
of people like playing NetHack
without copying saves.
Because they're good enough at
that game, if they die it was
because they were clumsy.
Its an execution thing.
But going back to the idea that
the pipeline was so empty
in the '90s, the pipeline is
really full now for games.
So if your game is too hard
you're either going for core
audience, and I think something
like Demon's Souls
is a perfect example of
a core audience game.
Who is looking for
that kind of--
they're the same people who
throw themselves out of
airplanes, right?
I mean,--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yes.
WOLFF DOBSON: They're looking
for that challenge.
You do wing suits and fly
down sides of mountains.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Squirrel
suits.
WOLFF DOBSON: Just that
somebody's looking--
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: While playing
Demon's Souls.
WOLFF DOBSON: --for something
challenging.
While in with a broad market and
a lot of people playing,
and a lot of kids playing, you
just don't want to keep
punching your audience
in the eye.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I don't know if
this made the last episode,
but we were talking
about the stats of
game completion rates.
And it's very low, like 30% of
the audience makes it to the
end of the game.
So by, there's an incentive
there, I think, for game
developers to make the game
easier and easier to be
successful in and complete so
that people feel like they've
got their money's worth and they
are also very proud of
themselves because, hey,
I beat this game.
Even though they've
made it so simple.
WOLFF DOBSON: Too easy.
TODD KERPELMAN: As someone that
has less time to play
games, I appreciate the fact
that I can make it through a
lot of the content without
having to replay the same
level multiple times.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: I think--
I forget which games on the Wii
did this, but they had a--
I think there was a Mario game
for the Wii where if you died
eight times they would actually
allow the computer to
play the stage for you.
WOLFF DOBSON: Show you how.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: And then once
you made it past the part you
couldn't make it passed before
you just press a button and
you're back playing the game.
WOLFF DOBSON: They also had a
really neat thing when you're
playing with friends.
If somebody dying all the time
they can just bubble up and
just follow you.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Oh.
OK.
WOLFF DOBSON: So only one person
has to be good at the
incredibly difficult
time jumps.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: So more
mechanisms to make it easier.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, more
mechanisms to make it so
people can stay together.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Yeah.
Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think
that's cool.
I'm with Todd.
I like easy games.
TODD KERPELMAN: I didn't
say I like easy.
I just like being able to make
it through without having to--
WOLFF DOBSON: I like
being challenged.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: I like
doing nothing.
COLT MCANLIS: I like games
I have to program
algorithms to beat.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
Well, we are, I think, a
little over time now.
So we're going to wrap up.
But we'll be back in a couple
weeks and we'll hopefully come
up with some other interesting
questions.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: Now tell your
friends about this show.
TODD KERPELMAN: Yeah.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
I actually, I really like the
fact that we had a lot more
questions this time.
So tell your friends.
Have them all ask any sorts
of gaming question.
WOLFF DOBSON: Keep sending in
those cards and letters.
TODD KERPELMAN: Fewer
Android questions.
Were generally not
the Android guys.
They have their own show.
We don't talk to them.
WOLFF DOBSON: You can ask
us Android questions.
JOHN MCCUTCHAN: If there are
certain games you want us to
review or talk about feel free
to throw up some questions.
WOLFF DOBSON: Sure.
And if you have games that you
think we should be playing,
either because they're
too hard or they're
too easy, you should--
COLT MCANLIS: Then
send them to us.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
Send them to us.
We'd love to see them.
COLT MCANLIS: For free.
TODD KERPELMAN: All right.
We got to go.